foreign
[Music]
ahead on lawn crime daily the deadly
Uvalde school shooting thoughts and
prayers are wonderful but and important
but they are not enough and actions
speak louder than words and we must take
action why officials say emergency
responders didn't do enough plus
disgrace comedian Bill Cosby is found
liable in a decades-old sexual assault
case this is a great Victory not only
for our client but for other
persons who allege they are victims of
child sexual abuse and the Pike County
Massacre when Jake
came in and he sat down with us and he
told us what happened
it absolutely
erased the hookah what key witness could
testify when George Wagner IV stands
trial for murder but first Justin Ross
Harris's murder conviction is overturned
for the 2014 death of his toddler son
Cooper long crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you welcome everyone to Modern
crime daily I'm your host Brian buckmar
a Monumental ruling by the Georgia state
supreme court as the murder conviction
of Justin Ross Harris is overturned back
in 2016 Harris was convicted in the 2014
murder of his 22-month-old son Cooper
Harris told officials he forgot to drop
Cooper off at daycare before driving to
work after that he left Cooper in the
back seat of the vehicle for about seven
hours in the 80 degree heat of Atlanta
Georgia the boy later died Harris was
sentenced to life in prison plus an
extra 32 years when he was found guilty
on eight charges Harris appealed his
conviction of murder and first-degree
child cruelty earlier this year on
Wednesday the Georgia state supreme
court overturned Harris's murder
conviction saying jurors were shown a
quote extensive amount of improperly
admitted evidence at the time of the
trial Harris was also convicted of sex
crimes involving a then 16 year old girl
prosecutors used that information to
argue Harry first intentionally killed
Cooper to be free of his child in its
order the Georgia Supreme Court ruled
there is no relevant connection between
Harris's sex crimes and a motive to
murder his son while Harris's murder
conviction was overturned the court
upheld his sex crimes conviction
joining us today is co-host Terry Austin
and criminal defense attorney Karen
Nance Karen prosecutors convincingly
painted Justin Ross Harris as a sexual
predator but the Supreme Court slapped
that down saying that doesn't mean he's
a murderer is there truth behind that
logic
I think with this particular case Brian
there is truth behind it because we're
talking about different offenses that
this particular person is committed
clearly he is guilty uh he was found
guilty of both but the court set this
aside because you need separate evidence
you need to have independent evidence
that's not related to his the sexual
crimes that he committed so he has to
have a new trial so that that
information will be handled separately
and it's been addressed separately so I
think in this case the court was correct
in setting aside uh the verdict with
regard to the murder yeah both horrible
crimes but simply being a sexual
predator doesn't necessarily make you a
murderer well Terry so what happens now
does Justin Ross Harris receive a new
trial for the alleged murder of his son
so that's exactly what's going to happen
Brian he's going to get a new trial for
that murder conviction but as far as
those sexual crimes are concerned he's
going to keep that conviction and stay
in jail in fact he didn't even appeal
that conviction but the D.A has already
stated that they plan to file a motion
to reconsider I'm assuming if they do
that they are going to lose that motion
most of the emotions that are made for
reconsiderations are denied because
you're going before the same judge and
if that's the case then he'll go back
he'll get a new trial it'll be a new
jury it'll be new evidence maybe some of
the same evidence and it starts all over
again yeah it'll be interesting to see
what the motive will be now if it's not
the fact that he's trying to get away
from his family and without motive hold
up in front of a jury of his peers will
obviously continue to follow that case
with new developments and for the first
time the families of Gabby Patito and
Brian laundry face off in court ahead of
a possible Civil Trial Gabby Batino made
national headlines last fall after she
was reported missing in early September
her family told officials she had been
on a cross-country road trip with her
fiance Brian laundry patino's body was
later found in Grand Teton National Park
her cause of death was ruled to be
strangulation after a weeks-long Manhunt
laundry's remains were discovered in a
Florida Reserve authorities determined
he died by Suicide along with his
remains investigators found a written
confession where laundry admitted to
killing potato months later patito's
parents filed a civil suit against Chris
and Roberta laundry arguing Brian
laundry told his parents about patito's
murder in late August of last year and
that they later helped conceal his
location before he went missing on the
next episode of Law and crime daily
we'll take a closer look at Wednesday's
motion hearing and in California the
justice department announce it it is
dropping some fraud charges against
disgrace attorney Michael avenatti this
comes after he agreed to plead guilty to
several charges last week the already
incarcerated lawyer was accused of
swindling clients out of millions of
dollars in settlement funds and
obstructing the IRS as it attempted to
collect millions in unpaid payroll taxes
from a company avenatti operated the U.S
attorney's Office in California says it
won't move forward with the 31 counts of
wire fraud bank fraud and tax related
charges the 51 year old is already
serving five years in prison for two
other convictions including stealing
book proceeds from his former climate
client Stormy Daniels as she went public
about a hush money scheme surrounding
alleged affair with former president
Donald Trump he's also serving time for
trying to extort Athletic Company Nike
avenatti is scheduled to be sentenced in
September he faces a maximum of 83 years
in prison but his sentence will likely
be much shorter
still ahead on Law and crime daily
disgrace comedian Bill Cosby is found
liable in a civil sexual assault case
but first we head to Pike County Ohio
where a member of the Wagner family will
soon stand trial for murder
[Music]
welcome back an Ohio Judge rules Jake
Wagner can testify against his brother
at George Wagner IV's upcoming trial
both Wagners and their parents are
charged in the so-called Pike County
Massacre it happened in the remote Ohio
County in 2016 when eight members of the
rhodian family seven adults and one
teenager were found shot and killed
three children at the murder scene were
left alive years later members of the
Wagner family were arrested in
connection to the massacre mother Angela
Wagner father George Billy Wagner and
Sons Edward Jake Wagner and George
Wagner IV were charged with the murders
investigators say Jake Wagner shared
custody of his daughter with Hannah
Rogan investigators say that dispute led
to the murder last year Jake and Angela
Wagner admitted to the crime agreeing to
testify against Billy and George IV
prosecutors agree that if Jake testifies
truthfully the death penalty for his
family members will be taken off the
table at a hearing on Tuesday George
Wagner the fourth attorney argued that
Jake Wagner's testimony should be
suppressed at Jordan's coming trial
after the motion the prosecution
countered
the state gets to determine the value of
this testimony once he testifies it's
our position that this is such
a coercive plea agreement that it
violates the process not only under the
U.S Constitution but the Ohio
Constitution as well the defendant wants
this court in the community
to believe that the state's entire case
hinges on Jake Wagner and that's just
not the truth
look you're out of the state had a
powerful powerful and strong case
against the Wagner plan both
collectively and individually before the
state was even indicted before well
before we got to this point
well before Jake and Angela decided to
cooperate and and give us their
testimony in the end a judge denied the
defense's motion to suppress Jake
Wagner's testimony George Wagner IV's
trial is set to begin in August
Terry do you think the Judge made the
right ruling in letting Wagner's brother
testify were there arguments that you
think the defense should have made
you know I definitely think the Judge
made the right decision here I believe
that in exchange for this guilty plea
and testifying Jake Wagner is basically
saying look I'm not going to spend the
rest of my life in prison and I am
negotiating for the rest of the family
not to spend the rest of their life in
prison I don't think there was any
violation of due process that's what the
defense was trying to argue because
there is an ability to cross-examine and
also I think the defense had another
good argument about the fact that he is
not testifying on information that that
alone will convict him there's other
information that will convict him so I
think the other thing he could have
argued is that listen No One Can Do
consideration for someone else and maybe
that argument might have won but I
definitely think it was the right
decision yeah Karen maybe I'm projecting
as a defense attorney but if I hear and
I'm representing uh George Wright in a
situation that his brother is going to
testify I'm going to look to my client
and be like maybe we should take a plea
so do you think we're on the road to a
trial or a plea now that brother's going
to testify against brother
I think it's a time to for the his
counsel to to have a serious
conversation with him we're talking
about his mother Angela and his younger
brother Jake prepared to testify against
him uh to save themselves basically to
for the offer of a better deal so I
think that that gives reason to pause
and and he has to determine whether it's
worth taking the risk is it worth making
this Gamble and going forward he already
has his family members who are going to
testify against him I don't see the
benefit in moving forward uh and I don't
know if there's another offer on the
table for him but I think that uh we
have him and his in his father's case
still pending so it'll be interesting to
see how he would proceed but I think
that he should cut his losses and plead
at this point yeah often the last person
to turn on the group is the one who gets
the worst offer we'll see how this plays
out maybe the Opera is so bad he has to
go to trial we don't know we'll keep it
up an update on that and in Florida the
candy the dog Civil Trial is set to
resume on Thursday after are multiple
jurors tested positive for coven 19. the
case stems from an incident in 2016 when
defendant Zachary dieterle shot and
killed candy a terrier mix the lawsuit
was brought on by Rodney Jacobson
Candy's owner and a witness to the
shooting Dita Lee claims the dog was in
an attack stance when he shot her local
officials say dieterlee was not charged
because he had a permit to carry the
weapon and fear for his life and that he
was within his rights to use deadly
force because he feared that he would
die Jacobson says can he had no history
of aggression he says the ultimate goal
of the trial is for the Sarasota
Sheriff's Office to determine the share
the shooting was not justified and to
file criminal charges against dieterlee
the trial took a break starting Tuesday
when three jurors received a positive
diagnosis for coven 19. stay with the
law and crime daily for the latest
developments when Court reconvenes
coming up on lawn crime daily the Uvalde
school shooting why Texas officials say
the emergency response was an abject
failure plus famed women's rights
attorney Gloria Allred gives her take on
the Bill Cosby verdict
[Music]
welcome back a verdict is in as a
California jury finds disgrace actor
Bill Cosby liable in a civil case
surrounding nearly 50 year old sexual
assault allegations the lawsuit brought
by now 64-year-old Judy Huff claimed the
embattled comedian sexually assaulted
her at the Playboy mansion in the 1970s
when she was just 16 years old Hoth
claims she met Cosby at a park where he
was filming a movie she says he later
invited them to the Playboy Mansion
where he molested her it's the first
civil case to make it to trial since
qasi was released a year ago after his
criminal conviction for a sexual assault
alleged by a different woman was
overturned the jury began deliberations
on Thursday and reportedly had decided
on most of the verdicts by Friday
afternoon one juror was dismissed for a
prior commitment so the remaining panel
was forced to start deliberations over
again late Tuesday afternoon jurors
awarded a huff five hundred thousand
dollars in Damages but no punitive
damages were awarded Cosby was not
present for the trial or the verdict his
attorneys say they plan to appeal law
and Cryin spoke with Gloria Allred who
has represented more than 30 Cosby
accusers including Judy Huff
I am so so happy that the jury
understood what the truth was that we
were working to prove and and believed
that our client Judy Huff was uh the
victim of child sexual abuse by Bill
Cosby when she was 16 years old at the
Playboy Mansion this happened in
1975. so this case is the first case to
go to trial under the new child victims
act in California which allows adult
survivors of child sexual abuse to sue
their per their perpetrators those they
accuse even many decades later so this
is Justice for an important victim Judy
huff and it's an inspiration to so many
others throughout the world this is a
great Victory not only for our client
but for other
persons who allege they are victims of
child sexual abuse
well Terry Bill Cosby has won an appeal
in the past do you think he could go two
for two on this civil case
you know what Brian anything is possible
and it depends on whether or not their
grounds for appeal here I don't think
that there are we have heard that the
attorney spokesperson for Bill Cosby has
said they're going to appeal apparently
they spoke to a couple of jurors who
said that they voted in favor of Bill
Cosby but here this is a Civil Trial he
won his appeal in that other criminal
trial here there only needs to be a
majority not a unanimous verdict so I
don't think there are any grounds here
the jurors are allowed to have different
opinions as long as the majority votes
one way yeah now Karen what's next
um now that Bill Cosby has found liable
criminal charges collecting damages how
does that work
well of course as his team has indicated
they're going to file an appeal but the
act that um Gloria Allred referred to
the and I'm in California the uh
California child victims act is in place
until December 31st of this year so I
believe it's going to open the
floodgates she's already indicated miss
all red that there are other victims
waiting to move forward so I think that
the victory in this case being the very
first case that has used this statute to
the benefit to their benefit I think
that there are many other victims that
are going to come forward that she'll
probably represent and I think that he's
going to have many more lawsuits on his
hands all right yeah I would expect the
same as well based on the allegations
against him
also in celebrity news the father of
Britney Spears now requests the pop star
be deposed alleging his daughter made
inaccurate claims of abuse during her
conservatorship
Spears was notably released from her
conservatorship last year after spending
more than a decade with her father Jamie
Spears acting as conservator with
control over her finances and medical
decisions the conservatorship was
established in 2008 when Britney Spears
was placed in a psychiatric hold for
mental health concerns during the
conservatorship the pop star alleges her
father was abusive by wiretyping her
bedroom and forcing her to be put on
contraception now Jamie Spears hopes to
legally challenge his daughter's claims
of abuse by requiring the singer to
answer questions under oath this comes
as Britney Spears continues to post
about the conservatorship on her social
media and announced plans to write a
memoir about her time under the
conservatorship
when we come back did First Responders
react appropriately to the Uvaldi school
shooting why Texas officials say those
first of the scene should have done more
welcome back to lawn crime daily new
details now emerging about the Rob
elementary school shooting in Uvalde
Texas as state officials meet following
the incident nearly a month ago an 18
year old man broke into Rob Elementary
School with a gun and killed 19 students
and two teachers while in the school for
over an hour the shooter fired more than
a hundred rounds much of the attention
after the fact has been focused on the
response of local law enforcement and
the decisions made by the school
district's police chief the latest
details revealed by the director of the
Texas Department of Public Safety on
admission that a door to the classroom
where the school shooter was held up was
actually unlocked while police searched
for a key to get in he suggested that
day the lives of police officers were
more valued than the children inside the
classroom as gunfire tore through the
school Senators on both sides of the
aisle shared powerful messages at the
Texas state Committee hearing this week
there are just so many issues
but at the heart of it it's a societal
issue
we need help from moms and dad being
involved in their children's lives I
hope that all of us can pray to the Lord
for inspiration that we do and we say
and we make the right recommendations
that we all keep an open mind and listen
to all the solutions offered because we
have to take action
thoughts and prayers are wonderful but
and important but they are not enough
and actions speak louder than words and
we must take action we must make a
difference I'm also
a believer of faith and understand that
the next shooter is already walking the
streets
he's already out there she's already out
there whoever that is it's already there
it's it's the world I live in on this
side of heaven so to speak
my job
is to thwart the success of the next
attempt to the best of our abilities
when the afternoon it was decided that
the Robb County Elementary School where
the shooting happened will be torn down
Karen according to what we know so far
the police could have stopped the
shooting three minutes after the gunman
entered the school how will that affect
the mounting civil suits
well I think that there's a lot of
thinkers to point in this particular
case and we're talking about a really
tiny area and they just don't have the
funds we have the police response issue
we have gun safety and we have school
security and so all those issues come
into play and we don't want to bankrupt
this little town so I think that that's
going to be a soul-searching issue and
how can we resolve the issues as as
we're as we're just indicated in this
clip without bankrupting this little
town absolutely now Terry what happens
to a police department when their
actions are called quote an abject of
failure and so many lives are lost
well you heard there in that press
conference that everyone is very upset
the mayor is talking about demolishing
the school as you mentioned we could see
terminations particularly of the chief
Arredondo there will be an internal
review no doubt about it we're going to
look at policies and training and we
might even see that the Department of
Justice will come in and look at whether
or not there are issues that are
prevalent in that police department and
whether or not they need to change all
of their policies so we'll see what
happens Brian but lots of things need to
be done yeah the focus is right now in
the police but our hearts and Minds also
go out to those victims thank you for
those joining us here on Long crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
[Music]
thank you
[Music]